rallye je crois que vous voulez prendre
la parole avec agathe est ce que c'est
vrai qu'il y revoilà je veux finir ma
vie toi du tout pas du tout générale
mixte non mais dites la vérité on pas du
tout l'esprit moi je vais envoyer j'ai
envoyé un texto hier soir à agathe qui
m'a répondu ce matin et
voilà tout simplement est effectivement
comme dans un groupe d'individus on est
tous très différents alors sur le fond
je ne la rejoindrait jamais par rapport
à ce qu'elle a dit mais c'est pas bien
grave on n'est pas obligé d'être tout le
temps d'accord en tout cas je ne serais
jamais sur ce point là avec elle sur la
forme
effectivement comme je l'aï dit j'ai
trouvé que c'était dévastateur et que
c'était beaucoup trop injuste et
beaucoup trop voilà sur elle et c'était
vraiment très très désagréable et donc
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment pas bien et pour
le reste eh bien oui on a une sorte de
groupe alors il ya des coups de griffes
des coups de coeur des voilà des on a
des coups de riffs l'ap
oui mais où mais on peut aussi avoir des
plus que ça d'accord sur les programmes
est en désaccord profondément sur les
points de vue moi je pense qu'on fait
pas de politique mais que là malgré tout
c'est aussi politique de parler de ça et
c'est très bien aussi qu'on parle de ça
dans cette émission
et moi j'ai aucun problème avec agathe
comme je lui dis voilà moi je n'y a
aucun souci à agathe tu veux pas
redonner à ces [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
merci nana toits et jusque là non pardon
à mes jeux parce que j'ai envie de
repasser demain pour voir l'application
avec géraldine marie-mai et géraldine je
trouve qu'elle ressemble à javier
pastore déjà si bien fausse pas tu veux
tu voudrais déjà dit oui du podium était
la soeur de radian les rencontrer il
m'avait révélé un épisode de bruce
banner bien jouer comme ça ça veut dire
qu'ils aiment bruit c'est vrai tout
second degré c'est oui me l'a dit tous
les jours
on a des gens on a déjà une affaire pour
la dire
c'est un feuilleton cette émission est
bien c'est que tu veux faire même la
semaine prochaine le toit quand même aux
leurs maris faut plus de projets pas de
problème mais c'est grave ce n est pas
l'inviter agathe non non non mais ça va
j'ai géré à dîner et jean-marie vous
connaissez mon ego la radio
elle me dit on a été un an la radio
ensemble c'était moi l'animateur j'étais
pas là du tout tu vois non mais c'était
alors à gaz qu'est ce que voudrait dire
agir a dit évidemment que j'ai j'ai très
bien reçu le texto de gélatine a pris la
peine de m'écrire hier et que l'on vous
captez effectivement gg du réseau
téléphone non mais moi j'ai simplement
trouvé ça dommage que t'es pas eu plus
tôt la démarche de venir me parler
mercredi soir parce que tu étais là
jusqu'à tard dans les loges moi si je
restais jusqu'à maintenant rien enfin ce
que j'aimerais finir de l'homme est
juste en maintenant nommés justes
on sait ce qu'on passe dans l'émission
c'est un débat télé dans l'émission
c'est quand on met des bas dans les
loges
voilà on s'en fout non mais juste me
prévenir que te que tu allais avoir ce
ce discours qui était assez long assez
lourd juste me dire voilà moi je vais y
revenir je n'ai pas du tout d'accord
avec toi donc prépare toi parce que ce
qui va se passer c'est c'est moi contre
toi j'aurais j'aurais aimé que ça ça se
passe ça se passe un peu avant et que je
découvre pas ça en direct après comme je
te le dis moi j'espère juste que les
missions que j'adore ne ressemblera plus
jamais à la séquence à la séquence
d'hier soir que je pense parce qu on se
comprenait juillet et qui reflète pas
vraiment les relations qu'on a en vrai
tous ensemble et après j'ai pas trop
aimé juste là vous l'emmenez agathe oui
pour la conduire qui est ce qu'on a aimé
ou pas là ce soir j'aimerais vraiment
qu'on soit dans une athlète mais c'est
vrai on est une famille oui mais non
mais il faut lire oui donc allez c'est
fini c'est voilà l'analogie de je suis
ta mère donc je te parle de façon très
infantilisante ça ça ne marche pas moi
je souhaite de tout mon coeur à ta fille
de ne jamais vivre ce que la séquence
qui a été initiée hier ce que c'était
très dur et tue le tue l'a reconnu
tulard connu bien après après
effectivement on est une famille ici
donc il ya des frères et soeurs qu'on
adore qu'on aime par dessus tout des
cousins avec qui on rigole des
personnels convient donc tu rigoles
c'est pas jean-michel
huit ans après tête et à des membres de
la famille un peu plus éloigné que tu
prends plaisir à voir une fois par an
pour pour les fêtes pour les fêtes de
noël et c'est très bien aussi mais mais
là où je sais qu'on a un point commun
toi et moi et qui pour moi supplante
tout le reste c'est que quand cette
émission était dans l'oeil du cyclone
l'année dernière qu'il y a eu énormément
de polémique que tout le monde nous
taper dessus
certains autour de cette table qui je
pense ont été beaucoup plus violent que
toi et de mauvaise foi ont complètement
disparu et non plus répondu tu veux
aller de matthieu delormeau calme-toi
non mais là on va pas repartir sur un
autre 12 inclus parce qu'on est on ne
touche bien sûr olympiades et merci à
l'habitude la réveiller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est et on est que tout cela ensemble
et moi je pense que c'est ce qu'il faut
retenir qu on se soutient dans les
moments difficiles et je te soutiendrai
si jamais un jour tu as besoin du
soutien je te les donnerait toujours et
je ne tends fonds serait jamais alors
mesdames
voilà j'ai fait moi je peux maintenant
me plaît allez vous vous parlera après
tanger driver venir agathe qu'en fait je
n'ai rien fait en secret j'ai dit tout
ce que j'allais te dire hier à la prod
et à la rédaction en chef de l'émission
donc voila moi je suis complètement à
l'inversé pour cela bah voilà ben
apparemment ils vous aiment pas vous
leur direct voilà